Kongo versus missiles huh dodge em up
you think I'm afraid of your [ __ ]
missiles what's too big you ain't gonna
get past my defense I've improved the
strength of my buttcheeks and you ain't
this time is going to be the winner
because I'm just going to lie flat
present my buttocks you're all a bunch
of liars oh god don't kill me okay oh
you troll I saw that last one oh my god
I have to hop over you well how do you
do I know it's not exactly a Western
thing to be in a desert and talk to all
southern to a camel but oh boy you have
the lifeless soulless eyes of a demon
excuse me while I just pump on your
Rumpy hub fries Pro Plus bonus it's like
no those are just the spasms of the
babies stabbing me oh okay all right
let's try this one more time with less
stupid ones with my legs alright that'll
that'll stop them yep that'll off oh let
me just hold you I'll take this from you
god damn it my face wait you demon
children aren't gonna get the best of me
I know how to defeat you
apparently holy [ __ ] I'll just oh my god
you think you can beat me oh geez you
can probably beat me through that yeah
that ain't good
that ain't good give give give give give
give oh I got him oh hello why am i
grabbing the DES ball
oh this probably isn't good rope soccer
3.0 blah I've never played a game of
soccer in my life
Kenny tell impassible I will see about
that babe all right don't
okay is it over ah [ __ ] that ain't gonna
do it
type the box really is there it s damn
it are you oh hey all right P L yeah
okay
three D challenge fastest wins a
shout-out in my next level well I'm
already not fastest because I
rope swing 12 desert slaughtered with
barely minimal damage I'm the best wrong
spike fall okay long spike fall a little
bit farther out okay
well that turned out pretty well for me
I don't know what's gonna happen oh [ __ ]
and you go by two okay and then one more
for the road no get away
alright spike fall I can do this don't
move
oh god I don't know if I should move
yeah I move just a tiny bit is that
gonna ruin everything
I'm sacrificing baby
impossible if there's a hole there God
all right fine
two can play that game I'll go go in the
hole it went in my hole [ __ ] apparently
this one's digging with me okay
everything's fine
Oh golly golly golly golly everything's
fine okay everything's still kind of
fine all right now oh no not a torture
chamber
Oh No I don't want to click why do I
gotta click it okay pretty par for the
course when it comes to happy wheels
click not really torture more execution
chamber
Oh ain't gonna be good I'm so sorry why
the boom boxes why the boom oh god no
just jump dude
all righty then Oh pelvic thrusts holy
[ __ ] oh you have such a strong grundle
Wow
welcome to pogo fight three you ready
old man [ __ ] that was just warm up I
just won you intimidate Kona eventually
that's right that's what I thought
all right you ready old lady that's
right I called you old that's gonna kill
him with your machete and that was
actually a pretty good move oh oh [ __ ]
my tower now [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you yeah break your knees and
your [ __ ] Oh Oh No
I've broken everything of yours hello
hatchet head how you doing do you like
your hat with hedges hatches oh hello
king towering hat of machette ah [ __ ]
the horrors park Oh No it's so spooky
out here you think whoa was that a ghost
ego oh you ain't gonna get me ain't
nobody gonna get me what do I do here oh
[ __ ] ah well took care of her glad that
happen oh my boy well I've got this
permanent addition to my family and I'll
never ever get out of here again
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye